[Musique]
3 2 1 cédric villani bonjour bonjour
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle singer view
on vous reçoit dans le cadre de votre
rapport sur l'intelligence artificielle
intelligence artificielle diligentée par
le gouvernement
présentez-vous succinctement qui êtes
vous cédric villani 43 ans mathématicien
membre de l'académie des sciences et
député de pour la république en marche
je suis actuellement en charge d'une
mission sur l'intelligence artificielle
mais plus généralement je m'intéresse
beaucoup à des sujets ou scientifique
rencontre le politique et d'enseignement
mathématiques c'est une autre mission
les rapport de l'office parlementaire
scientifiques sur des sujets
scientifiques intéressés l'action
publique que ce soit les vaccins la
bioéthique
le rôle de la grippe dans la vie
publique etc alors on n'a pas l'habitude
de recevoir les politiques pendant notre
année uniquement pendant les élections
donc on pose des questions genre vous
avez un compte caché vous avez un casier
judiciaire pas qu'on cache et pas de
casier judiciaire et jour dans votre
déclaration d'impôts
alors en tant qu'auto entrepreneur j'ai
un retard sur ma déclaration diffusée à
tva ouais tva et puis il faut que je me
déclare pour je sais plus quoi parce que
n'est ce pas ce sort un
coffret de conférence à la maison des
métallos pour lequel j'interviens en
tant qu'auteur et en tant qu'acteur
parce que c'était moi sur scène qui
faisait le stand-up bon et en tant
qu'acteur il faut que je me déclare
selon je sais plus quelle procédure
franchement donc je suis pas
complètement à jour de mes déclarations
mais honnêtement c'est sur un petit
montant académie des sciences vous
connaissez notre pote jacques dahm
j'avoue que non son moteur du programme
spatial français on en reparlera ok donc
j'ai deux rives il a neigé l'académie
des sciences c'est une grande maison us
une grande maison vous y aller mercredi
c'est ça avant d'être en politique j'y
allais le mercredi sa joue bon on
revient à notre sujet l'intelligence
artificielle on en est où qu'est ce que
vous en pensez vous avez vu qu'ils où
est ce qu'on va les d'histoire là ça va
perturber quels secteurs d'activité on y
va alors commencer par afin qu'à
secteurs d'activité ça a perturbé tout
ce qu' on a vu tout le monde enfin a vu
des centaines de deux sens entre 200 et
250 personnes
on a vu des ingénieurs des
informaticiens
mais aussi des chefs d'entreprise même
si des juristes et avocats des des
gendarmes des médecins on a vu tout le
monde et
l'intelligence artificielle ça va venir
s'inviter dans tous les secteurs dans
tous les métiers et c'est ça qui est
passionnant ce qui fait que ce rapport
est passionnant parce que nous permet de
plonger dans les entrailles de tout un
tas de secteurs et d'imaginer
l'évolution technologique de leur
secteur ensemble alors où on en est
on à identifier les axes majeurs de
notre rapport
certain nombre de mesures on doit les
plus fines et de réfléchir au chiffrage
on doit surtout rédigé le document final
on a encore deux mois pour faire ça et
ce qui est important pour nous c'est que
on veut faire un
document un rapport qui s'adresse à tout
le monde parce que c'est un sujet qui
concerne pas que les scientifiques il
est politique c'est un sujet qui nous
concerne tous et c'est un sujet qui est
passionnant parce qu'il
permet à tout le monde de se rencontrer
discuter par les deux grands sujets sur
société si un sujet qui est aussi plein
de mystère et c'est ça qu'on aime aussi
sur l'évolution de la discipline sur les
ressorts scientifique profond de
l'intelligence artificielle quelque
chose à faire
le petit nuit il fera un peu sur la
lavallière quand on postule habitué je
vais moi quelqu'un peut pencher un peu
voit donc
pédagogie sur l'intelligence
artificielle sensibiliser la population
la population elle est perméable
imperméable à ça quelles vont être les
mesures proactives pour la sensibiliser
on part de loin
puisque
on a des sondages récents qui nous
disent que en gros deux tiers des
français disent ne pas savoir ce que
c'est qu'un algorithme
deux tiers des français se disent
effrayés par l'intelligence artificielle
pas forcément les mêmes messages ou
aussi le fait de ne pas savoir ce que
c'est et voilà il ya un contexte général
qui est la peur
selon plusieurs ressorts
certain style intelligence artificielle
c'est un truc qui va échapper à ses
créateurs et qui va venir tous nous
réduire en esclavage comme dans matrix
ou dans 2001 l'odyssée de l'espace
certains se disent d'intelligence
artificielle c'est un truc qui va venir
piquer mon emploi et je vais vous
retrouver au chômage comprenant rien à
cette nouvelle société tout ça
et certains se disent intelligence
artificielle c'est un truc dans lequel
l'europe va être réduite à l'état de
colonies par les états unis ou part la
chine ça venir dans peu de temps ou dans
longtemps il ya toutes ces peurs
qui en partie sont des fantasmes mais
qui va convenir de
d'expliciter d'y répondre et d envisager
et quand on essaye de mettre les choses
sous le tapis d'endormir les gens avec
un discours lénifiant et à rennes mieux
pour aviver les peurs donc on cachera
pas par exemple le fait qu' on sait pas
vraiment comment va évoluer le marché du
travail sous l'effet de l'ia dans les
décennies à venir
oui c'est vrai qu'on a un retard par
rapport aux états unis et par rapport à
la chine aussi au moins sur les aspects
économiques de l'intelligence
artificielle
et oui c'est vrai que on sait pas quels
sont les ressorts scientifique profond
de certains algorithmes d'intelligence
artificielle qui sont hyper efficace
mais il faut pas avoir peur de tout ça
il faut
apprendre aussi quelles sont nos forces
comment on va aborder ces sujets de
société comment on va les mettre en
débat comment on va en parler et comment
on va se renforcer les mesures
proactives en premier on va mettre en
avant des chercheurs pour parler de leur
discipline parce qu'ils sont plus
crédibles et souvent plus intéressant
que certains qui sont souvent invitée
dans le débat
moi je parle de l'ia mais en tant que
politique et mathématicien je suis pas
un chercheur en y a ça sera j'aimerais
bien que des gens comme les jeunes qui
ont fondé la très belle start-up terra
pixels qui bientôt fera des diagnostics
sur le cancer du sein ou d'autres
cancers bien plus efficacement que des
humains ou des jeunes qui sont aux
commandes sur les nouvelles méthodes
dans la voiture autonome j'aimerais bien
leur donner la parole qu'ils puissent
parler d'eux comme c'est à la fois
passionnant de mener ces recherches est
comme ça les rend humble parce qu'ils
sont bien content que il faut essayer et
réessayer
donc mesures actives
m
donner à des gens la formation les clés
pour pouvoir parler publiquement du
débat intelligence artificielle à mettre
en place des défis qui permettront de
parler de ces sujets il parlait de la
recherche à 200 pourquoi pas revisiter
les 24 heures du mans avec des concours
de voitures autonomes pourquoi pas
trouver tel ou tel défi qui s'inscrira
dans un lieu de mémoire français ou
européens et qui sera l'occasion de voir
comment les différentes équipes abordent
et si vous avez parlé de la chine des
états unis de la colonie de la
colonisation numérique on va revenir dix
ans en arrière avec
la nsa keith et plug et sur beaucoup de
nos paille peu de data ou qui a mis des
sons d'un peu partout de façon ouverte
où souvent ouvertes sur sa capacité
d'interception mondial et même
françaises je rappelle que la nsa
intercepté des millions de communication
française
qui les a stocké dans des data center
sur son territoire comment ça se passe
le rapport de force avec ce type de
comportement prédateur sur nos data que
je rappelle les dates à son fait aussi
pour entraîner l'intelligence
artificielle quelle est la position du
gouvernement face à ça
en premier
il ya une approche
européenne
des données data qui est fort différente
de la proche américaine ou de la proche
chinoise et l'europe est très clairement
le continent sur lequel on tient le plus
compte de la vie privée des citoyens il
faut le dire il faut
tâcher de construire la confiance à
partir de ça
dans la loi les la réglementation tel
que le general data protection
régulation garantie certaine droite et
prg dpr alors l'acronyme français ça
doit être rg et
ça va venir imposer des nouveaux devoirs
aux entreprises dont les nouveaux droits
aux citoyens les droits tels que
portabilité quand vous changez
d'opérateur les différents opérateurs
devront ce communiqué et les données
qu'ils ont sur vous avec votre
consentement pour vous garantir la même
qualité de service il ya comme ça tout
un ensemble de règles de mesure qu'ils
sont qui seront importantes en deuxième
c'est important qu'on travaille sur la
souveraineté à l'échelle du continent
souveraineté ça veut dire
capable de faire les dires des
partenariats avec les grandes
entreprises étrangères oui mais être
capable aussi chaque fois qu'on chouette
de travailler sur une filière 100%
européenne avec des données stockées en
europe des centres de traitement des
informations européen des architectures
systèmes aussi qu'ils soient européenne
de sorte qu'on puisse dire oui sur les
sujets sensibles on reste entre
européens je vous coupe microsoft
s'est partenariat avec nos services
publics comme l'armée
comment maintenir à cette souveraineté
avec cette bague tour cette porte
dérobée
consentie ou
subis ouais qu'est ce qu'on fait en
premier il faut le dire même si il ya
une certaine forme de cyber colonisation
qui est en oeuvre maintenant
les grandes entreprises à l'oeuvre ils
sont pas aussi méchant qu'on aurait pu
le craindre dire ils ont un grand grand
pouvoir si demain facebook veut
influencer une grande élection un peu
n'importe où dans le monde de façon
importante facebook peut techniquement
le faire ça s'appelle s'appelle
profilage sa place de nature gestion
parlant des structures chine à structure
fing absolument c'est le parent et ça
vous permet de mais je n'ai pas que pas
que la structure fing ça c'est pour la
structure fine qui vous permet de faire
de rendre un sujet plus important qu'il
ne l'est en réalité de monter un grand
truc en buzz mais pouvez aussi vous
intéresser à
sélectionner les informations vous allez
envoyer
lancé les commentaires postés des
commentaires avec de l'intelligence
artificielle pour influencer la
perception de l'opinion publique c'est
ce que vous vouliez dire non d'accord
c'est carrément ça c'est là on est dans
la structure fing mais ce que peut faire
facebook en plus c'est carrément filtrer
les informations que vous recevez
le sadi ça va envoyer une fois l'un une
fois l'autre et les infos que vous
recevrez seront calibrées en fonction de
votre personnalité le filter bubble
exactement et on a des modèles de
personnalités qui fonctionne pas si mal
et on sait par exemple on a montré
qu'avec quelques dizaines de cliquer
sur une page facebook numérique on peut
déterminer ans avec très forte
probabilité si vous êtes blanc noir si
vous votez démocrate ou républicain
homosexuels alors ça c'est saint pois y
revenir mais évidemment qu'il ya aussi
des pour l'épauler cliquer oui et
évidemment quand on peut après l'essai
info venir à vous comme ceci ou comme
cela de sorte que
c'est le rêve du politique quoi pouvoir
dire une chose aux 1 et une autre chose
aux autres le rêve du politique sans
école vertébrale bien sûr et donc
facebook a les moyens techniques de
faire ça facebook ou google google
on voit pas qu'ils soient animés de
particulièrement mauvaise intention est
ce que vous pensez que le gars femmes
sont les pointes de diamant de services
ou de pouvoir étatique
est ce que l'entreprise est totalement
indépendante par rapport aux pouvoirs
étatiques on sait qu' il ya une
proximité entre les grands acteurs des
gars femmes et le gouvernement américain
on sait qu'à des réunions régulières sur
ce genre de sujet
et qui a une certaine perméabilité
transfert
information
je suis persuadé cependant que chez les
fondateurs chez les
personnes qui sont le plus en
responsabilité dans ces associations
globalement et à la volonté de servir le
bien qu est ce qui vous permet
d'affirmer sa sas et j'ai dit ce que je
pensais et puis d'avoir rencontré
certains discuter avec eux et tout ça et
puis quand on voit aussi leur leur
déclaration la façon dont 10 positionne
maintenant il faut pas être naïf c'est
une situation dangereuse c'est une
situation fragile et c'est une situation
qui n'est pas tolérable pour la
démocratie la souveraineté de l'europe
et tout en
remerciant la providence que ce pouvoir
soit pas tomber dans des mains qui ont
l'air mauvaise il faut travailler très
fort a assuré possible où tout nomi de
l'europe sur ces sujets à muscler les
citoyens par rapport à ce qu'il ou elle
laisse connaître deux sur les réseaux
sociaux sur les informations objets
connectés ou tout ce que vous voulez à
faire attention avec qui on passe des
contrats et je le dis très clairement
les services que j'eusse que je pense
c'est que les services publics
que ce soit éducation nationale soit le
dg ici pour prendre des exemples qui ont
été très commenté ces derniers temps
doivent accorder une préférence un
triptyque à des entreprises françaises
et européennes
et je serais même heureux que ça puisse
être inscrit dans la loi l'amérique a
une
loi forte ancien qui s'appelle le buy
american act j'adore des années 30 quand
il fallait relancer l'économie
américaine et qui dit qu'on donne une
préférence nationale quand c'est la
commande publique en une commande
publique puissance publique pour
s'équiper doit le faire en priorité
ils ont aussi en amérique une loi qui
s'appelle le small business act qui là
pour favoriser l'émergence et
l'accompagnement des petites structures
quand c'est possible et je serai aussi
favorable à ce qu'on ait la même chose
en europe c'est un sujet délicat
par rapport aux questions de droit de la
concurrence par rapport à la
réglementation européenne
mais c'est quelque chose déjà qu'on peut
avoir en tête à l'échelle française dans
ce genre de sujets critiques on s'équipe
intérêts stratégiques
c'est important pour la souveraineté de
s'équiper français et européens c'est
important aussi pour accompagner nos
acteurs et pour qu'ils puissent devenir
plus fort économiquement et
techniquement
la chine comment le chine est perçu par
l'europe et la france ce qu'elle est
perçue comme un prédateur le dragon
s'est réveillé ou puis le dragon c'est
réveiller le dragon est très fort et
même aux états-unis c'est perçu comme un
dragon féroce actuellement vue de la
silicon valley on observe l'émergence de
la chine avec beaucoup d'attention voire
d'inquiétude parce que la montée est
extrêmement rapide les bété x comme on
dit se sont construit encore moins de
temps que les dégâts femmes
ils ont
accès à quantité de données
il y a une structure politique chinoise
qui permet qui a permis à ces acteurs de
croître de façon très protégée et qui
leur assurent aussi toutes sortes de
facilité quand il ya besoin
il ya des concentrations de capitaux
considérables ça va très très vite
on a vu sur le site 1 certains
je pense que il faut être très attentif
au niveau du ceta je pense qu'on n'a pas
regardé d'assez près ces questions
des changes et de partenariat par
rapport aux données par rapport à tout
ce qui est
tout ce qui a trait aux rythmiques
le
quel on va dire le politique à
sensibilité écologiste qui est en moi
s'inquiète aussi de certaines possibles
dérives de ces accords par rapport à des
échanges qui pas un impact carbone
optimale ou à défaut faire attention
bien sûr l'ops et le continent dans
lequel on est plus attentif aux normes à
la protection de la santé du citoyen et
tout ça et il faut pas perdre ça si
c'est bien mis en oeuvre avec diligence
tout va bien mais il faut être vigilant
vous parler d'écologie parce que vous
connaissez 12h12
non j'aimerais qu'ils qui modéliser les
fondamentaux de soutenabilité d'une
société par exemple
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on peut dire
quand on conjugue demi dose
l'intelligence artificielle la finitude
de nos ressources
ni à c'est un ensemble de technologies
qui sont très gourmands comment d'un
matériel gourmande en énergie
on se représente naïvement
l'informatique comme un secteur
dématérialisée
mais ça une très forte en potes c'est
très consommateur en ressources qui sont
difficiles à recycler c'est très
consommateur en énergie et ça fera
partie de nos recommandations qu'on doit
avoir ça en tête
d'une part l'europe pourrait dans la
compétition mondiale doit se développer
en termes d'infrastructures de calcul en
particulier de plateformes mais notre
part on doit garder en tête notre
sensibilité européenne d'économies
ça veut dire faire attention à optimiser
les la construction des centres de
calcul
recycler la chaleur qui est produite
faire attention à l' architecture ça
veut dire travailler sur la mise en
place des architectures de calcul qui
soit aussi économe que possible ça veut
dire entre plusieurs solutions choisir
celles qui sont les plus économes
globalement big data et très coûteux en
énergie parce que non seulement cette
liste très grands volumes de données
mais ça passe son temps à les faire
passer et repasser à les explorer
explorer dans une approche statistique
il y a certaines technologies qui sont
encore plus coûteuse en énergie que
d'autres child très très coûteux parce
que vous faites travailler tous les
acteurs impliqués pour certifier votre
transaction avant de le déployer il faut
se demander à quelle échelle il faut le
déployer ce que c'est vraiment
nécessaire et ainsi de suite
ce qu'une intelligence artificielle et
le prochain cliquer malthusien
c'est dans les possibles quant à savoir
quel est le quai ce qui va arriver en
premier dans l'est dans ce débat sur les
limites des ressources de notre chère
planète je ne me risquerai pas à faire
une prédiction mais
il ya quelque temps
si je dis pas betis et l industrie des
semi-conducteurs qui dit qui tirait une
sonnette d'alarmé travers un communiqué
en disant attention si on continue à ce
rythme on va dans le mur pour ce qui est
du développement de l'industrie du
calcul parce que la demande en énergie
du secteur croît de plus en plus vite et
il faut prendre garde au fait que notre
dépense en énergie a pas vocation à
s'accroître sans limite j'ouvre une
parenthèse
est-ce que vous pensez que la plus
grande tare de l'humanité se son
incompréhension de la fonction
exponentielle
il ya quelque chose de l'étrange avec
les
humains c'est
l'incapacité à
collectivement prendre conscience quand
il ya un réel
enjeu de survie grave à l'échelle
planétaire
mais je dirais pas que c'est la
compréhension de la fonction
exponentielle qu'il principal problème
je dirais c'est plutôt dans les
questions de théorie des jeux décision
collective le climat est un excellent
exemple voyez comme ça a été tellement
dur d'arriver à des accords sur le
climat peine ils ont été pris ils ont
commencé à être remis en cause on voit
comment la 2e tour que prend la
discussion aux états unis on a envie de
dire des fois collectivement au lkp
comment vivez vous allez vous lie à en
péril péril en la demeure et
collectivement institutionnellement du
mal n'arrive pas alors certains ont dit
ça fait un moment déjà que j'en dis
intrinsèquement une démocratie c'est
lent à réagir ou ça a du mal s'est
lancée l'an parce qu'elle la question de
se décider puis c'est dicté souvent par
le temps court parce qu'il ya le rythme
des élections
je fais partie de ceux qui pensent que
le projet de
nouvelles institutions politiques qui
pourrait s'appeler chambre du temps long
ou quelque chose comme ça qui a été mis
en avant par exemple par la fondation
selon gbo foundation s'est cependant
selon beau fond des choses se passent
aussi passé le site enfin en france en
tout cas c'est porté par la fondation
nature et hommes classiquement appelé
fondation nicolas hulot
qui prône la mise en place d'une chambre
d'une troisième chambre aux côtés de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat et qui
elle aurait pour vocation
de participer au processus de la loi en
particulier en interpellant les
assemblées sur le thème en regardant les
conséquences à long terme avec des
principes venant de pair avec des
principes constitutionnels tels que
impossibilité de régression dans le
droit de l'environnement sur
l'état dans lequel la planète et
transmises et avec une réflexion de long
terme dans laquelle on s'interroge sur
les effets des effets sur
l'environnement les effets sur le climat
et on
tient compte de ça dans le processus de
fabrique de la loi
et où les personnes qui siégeraient
serait un mix entre des représentants
des citoyens des représentants des ong
des représentants de
d'institutions d'institutions
scientifiques
on va parler entraînement de
l'intelligence active artificielle
de valeur de où on va
qui entraîne à ce que celui qui entraîne
à des responsabilités
ce qu'il faut utiliser des moines
bouddhistes pour entraîner nous prochain
robot tueur
alors
ce qui est clé bien sûr mais comme vous
l'avez bien définis à travers votre
question il y a une responsabilité dans
l'entraînement qui est un grand
changement par rapport à l' approche
traditionnelle de l'informatique où on
disait bon algorithme si le truc est
bien codé il va donner une bonne
décision avec l'intelligence
artificielle statistiques qui seulement
l'une des méthodes
d'apprendre d'apprentissage avec cette
méthode là
la qualité et la quantité des exemples
qu'on donne à manger à la machine compte
aussi et donc la responsabilité partagée
les concepteurs et les entraîneurs
ça veut dire ce qui va y avoir de
nouvelles compétences qui vont être
définis
certification de base de données
collègues de base de données
ça veut dire que dans les spécifications
dont on sait bien que c'est là la
première étape indispensable à la mise
en place d'un bon algorithme et il
faudra se demander qu'est ce qu'on veut
comme exemple quels sont les biais qu'on
veut éviter et
il faudra que collectivement on est un
accroissement en compétences du nouveau
métier qui vont apparaître il y à des
certificats qui vont se développer il va
falloir apprendre à débusquer des biais
qui pourraient être des billets en
fonction de la source qui pourraient
être des billets parce qu'on n'a pas
fait les bonnes recherches qui vont nous
apprendre beaucoup aussi sur nous mêmes
et vous entendez pas à prendre sur nous
mêmes par exemple
si vous entraîner si vous êtes un drh
les faire des recrutements bien comme il
faut à partir de toute une base
d'exemples
si vous avez sans avoir conscience on
veut le croire adopter une attitude
sexiste dans vos recrutements
l'intelligence artificielle qui aura été
entraînés avec vos recrutements et sera
sexiste aussi et en analysant les biais
éventuel de cette ia vous pourrez
apprendre des choses sur vos propres
biais et on peut même imaginer qu'il ait
procédure de détection de bié qu'ils
soient basés sur ceux sur ce genre de
principe on entraîne avec tous les
exemples et on analyse ce qui ce qui en
sort est ce qu'il y a pas un risque de
standardisation des profils de la
population des sentiments si tout le
monde se sent épiée part de leur
reconnaissance faciale de la
reconnaissance de mouvements
de la reconnaissance
de texte dans la dialectique employés
dans le vocabulaire employé à ce que
veulent pas y avoir une standardisation
comme des poulets dans la population
alors d'abord jahl qu'un c'est ça et
sanae a déjà eu d'autres facteurs qui
ont joué à ça sans intelligence
artificielle
pour les politiques le regard magnétique
constant a été un facteur important de
son organisation on en revient dans
certaines occasions à faire gaffe à
chacun de nos maux à faire en sorte que
rien ne dépasse à utiliser d'éléments de
langage juste part pour éviter qu'un
truc qui dépasse un peu soit monté en
mayonnaise et que ça devienne une
polémique incontrôlable c'est parce que
vous faites ce soir j'espère soir je
suis très franc avec vous bien sûr mais
on n'est pas dans un contexte
communication politique ici
alors ce qui est
important a donc il faut bien prendre
conscience c'est que par rapport à façon
dont l'algorithme nous façonnent on
aussi le fur et à mesure et technologie
entre des peurs variés et si on revient
sur l'exemple de facebook des bulles des
choses comme ça on voit que en une
décennie peut-être
on est passé sur la question des réseaux
sociaux à une peur de la standardisation
à une preuve une peur de la
personnalisation à outrance
ayant encore 10 ou 15 ans on pouvait
dire facebook c'est un truc terrible
parce que tout le monde va penser pareil
tout la pensée américaine va être
envahi à tout le monde et on n'aura que
des gens qui pensent ont d'eux-mêmes et
maintenant c'est le contraire on a peur
de facebook en disant et des effets de
communauté qui font que les gens ne sont
plus liés par des références culturelles
communes ils se retrouvent dans leur
propre sphère de confort avec les
interlocuteurs qui pensent comme eux et
finalement c'est un outil à exacerber
des différences on a vu qu'on est passé
d'un extrême à l'autre en fonction de la
technologie et on peut se dire que
ça sera aussi à nous d'apprendre à
définir ce qu'on veut je ne veux pas
notre espace privé qu'est-ce qu'on veut
avoir comme
comme se faire de confort et comme ce
faire d'un confort la population est
prête à prendre son destin en main est
ce que la population vraiment peu
influencé
par nos peurs nos comportements par des
actions par le fait que ça quand ça
remonte aux politiques et ainsi de suite
et puis
j'ai à étonner pour 7 sur cette question
de où est ce que nous mène l'algorithme
je vais prendre un exemple
hyper simple qui est vraiment petit par
rapport aux grandes questions qu'on
évoque mais qui est qui certains d'entre
nous font à faire tous les jours c'est
la sélection sur youtube des algorithmes
qui vous mène d'un morceau de musique à
l'autre tant est qu'ils aient nettement
qui est pas mal fichu se sont ils ont
tellement tellement de d'utilisateurs
qu'ils sont obligés d'utiliser souvent
youtube j'utilise presque tous les jours
youtube est
typiquement je suis maudit tient
aujourd'hui je vais écouter de ceux ci
et à me suis dit allez je vais me faire
ma soirée en genesis et j'ai commencé à
mettre nursery cryme celle england by
the pound et tout ça et puis petit à
petit l'algorithme et mène une séance
très tard il m'a pas venir derrière ce
challenge en revanche il m'a emmené vers
des choses plus costaud alors on sait
bien il y va de proche en proche et puis
ils utilisent aussi les goûts les
personnels qu'on a déjà défini bon et
quand c'est bien quand c'est mal réglée
il vous fait tourner en rond et vous
réécouter sans arrêt est les morceaux
vous connaissez déjà et quand c'est bien
réglée il explore temps en temps des
sentiers vers lesquels vous seriez pas
embarquer un plein de morceaux que j'ai
découvert grâce à ce grâce à ses
algorithmes et
des fois j'ai envie je me dirais oui
peut-être que c'est possible d'ailleurs
j'ai pas regardé si on peut modifier les
paramètres pour que ce soit plus en
exploration ou plus dans la zone de
sécurité et c'est de ça qu'on a besoin
aussi pour les news qu'il n'arrive au
qu'on puisse définir soi même ah oui je
suis d'humeur exploratrice j'ai envie
d'aller dans une zone de confort la même
façon quand on est au kiosque à journaux
on peut se dire allez tient d'habitude
j'achète libération aujourd'hui j'ai
acheté le figaro aujourd'hui je vais
acheter l'humanité ou qui sait quoi pour
se pourvoir une son de cloche différent
et si on s'y prend bien les algorithmes
ils pourront faire ça très bien en
fonction de ce que nous on leur demande
mais il faut se prendre en main il faut
aussi avoir une idée de comment ça
fonctionne il faut aussi qu'on ait des
entreprises avec des valeurs auxquelles
on fait confiance qui saute aux manettes
il nous faut des champions européens des
champions français des gens qui sont
dans la proximité
face à tout ça
ce train qui part à grande vitesse cette
nouvelle technologie qui va vite même
trop vite pour certains est ce qu'on a
prévu des freins est ce qu'un monde sans
arty intelligence artificielle est
encore possible ce qu
est ce que vous saisissez ma question
est ce que j'aimerais qu'il est trop
trivial un monde sans ia
faut pas y compter et c'est le principe
de la démocratie mondiale un certain
sens à partir du moment où vous avez des
outils dia qui sont développés fort par
certains pays et où sont des outils qui
s'exporte qui se transporte évidemment
que
l'europe pas dire par exemple
unilatéralement stop toute la recherche
ni à ça renforcerait la cyber
colonisation et les effets indésirables
dont nous parlions
il ya au passage c'est pas un terme qui
bien défini c'est un ensemble disparate
de toutes sortes de techniques et
technologies
l'interdire ça vous dois aussi bien dire
on arrête on n'arrête le progrès
informatiques et la mise au point de
technologies
en revanche sur certains sujets ça va
être un enjeu de s'entendre au niveau
mondial et de la même façon qu'au niveau
du climat si on s'entend pas si on est
dans un climat de guerre économique
un climat ont fait de la géopolitique
sur notre chaîne on a questionné merlus
sur machine questionner les américains
si on s'entend pas et que les tensions
s'exacerbent que l'intelligence
artificielle est utilisé comme une arme
pour anticiper le comportement des
populations pour anticiper le
comportement du business pour anticiper
tout un tas de choses qui pourraient
influencer dans un
climat de tension il ya un ou deux
clauses viscéralement fait quoi on fait
quoi on commence par se préparer à tout
à subir on se prépare à se défendre
c'est un cet ancien on va dire comme
disaient les romains si vis pacem para
bellum si tu veux la paix m parra passe
m si tu veux la paix prépare la paix oui
mais si tu veux la paix prépare toi
prépare la guerre au sens prépare toi à
te défendre et
dans une négociation
pour imposer la paix en est d'autant
mieux armée si j'ose dire
que on a de la ressource en interne
ressourcer en premier les humains
intelligent et la ressource et
flexibilité agilité
est ce que la france est agile est ce
que la france verse ou ressent quand on
voit le quotient intellectuel européenne
bce oui c'est vrai le quotient
intellectuel européen baisse
pour rappeler cette rayonnement on est
dans la merde jusqu'au cou
nous on a des soucis mais on a encore
des avantages bon quels sont les
avantages par exemple on est un pays qui
respecte ces intellectuels qui respecte
ces chercheurs qui respecte et inventeur
du pays par ils n'ont pas de place où on
les paie guère c'est vrai mais on le
respecte c'est déjà ça
et puis on est un continent qui s'est
construit sur la défense
des droit privé la défense de l'humanité
on est le continent dans lequel les
droits du citoyen sont le plus pris en
compte dans les réglementations dans les
lois dans la politique ça c'est
important et on attend de nos dirigeants
qu'ils puissent faire porter cette voie
et ce respect des valeurs partout dans
le monde
vous parlez des
sujets tels que
de sujets tels que intelligence
artificielle utilisée à des fins de
guerre économique par exemple c'est déjà
le cas non c'est déjà le cas vous l'avez
nes inspiré depuis 15 ans nous de nous
data et les stocker l'eau bout du monde
ouais ça alors c'est pour ça aussi que
c'est important d'avoir des possibles
chaîne souveraine s'est pas trop tard et
c'est pas écouté jamais trop tard se
sont jamais trop tard en premier en
deuxième quand vous écoutez les acteurs
c'est que les investissements qui ont
été faits par les grands acteurs sur le
domaine et se comptent en dizaines de
milliards sur la dernière année des
milliards c'est beaucoup mais on est en
europe vous êtes un grand continent 8
yens 2 milliards on les mettra sur la
table s'il le faut ce sera de la tête
j'espère que ce sera beaucoup de
d'investissement j'espère que ce sera
aussi le plus possible en
partenariat on sait bien que c'est une
des
deux à tous les niveaux et par exemple
au financement des entreprises c'est une
des faiblesses de l'europe par rapport
aux états unis par exemple que la
plupart notre financement ferrandez
plutôt qu'en participation est peut-être
qu'on peut s'améliorer on va repartir
sur les valeurs morales et sociales
une question d'internet sur quel sur
quelle morale sociale entre parenthèses
pays slash communauté et cela chez etc
fermez la parenthèse vous être pro vont
être programme les il ya un four être
pourquoi j'ai pas compris des questions
là vont être programmées entre les il
a compris c'est que cette question non
il veut dire à quelqu es laquelle je
pense kaka est la référence qu'on
utilise pour oui si on va aller où on va
où est ce que c'est pour continuer ce
capitalisme prédateur est ce que c'est
pour continuer pour là à parler
trivialement est ce que c'est pour
continuer le délire de on aspire tous
fait tout acabit la planète exactement
ce qui entre parenthèses et vrais
conflits de la planète
l'ia c'est ce qu'on lit assez ce qu'on
en fera et nous les français prendront
ces gens mais aussi
les ong les politiques c'est ce qu'on en
fera et il faut bien y a pas besoin
d'être un génie pour utiliser l'ia n'y a
pas besoin d'avoir une giga grosses
installations pour utiliser lia et a
besoin de gros calculs oui il ya des
plateformes et y aura plus de
plateformes pour faire les calculs dans
l'avenir il ya et terrorisme comment ça
se passe alors il ya et terrorisme ça se
passe que les terroristes vont utiliser
de l'ia pour s'améliorer et les contres
terroristes vont aussi utiliser de l'ia
pour s'améliorer
les terroristes et ça c'est quelque
chose qui doit nous faire réfléchir on
était très fort dans l'embrigadement au
cours de ces dernières années et ont été
très forts pour utiliser les nouvelles
technologies par rapport à ça nous on a
été très faible tout ce qu'on veut on a
été très faible confère des politiques
de contrôle radicalisation absolument et
maintenant il va s'agir de s'emparer de
ça on veut que dans nos services de
police et de contre terrorisme il ya des
experts des fortiche en iran qu'ils
sachent comment détecter comment contrer
qui on veut globalement les liasses est
un sujet je dire je
prenais une arme monstrueuse comme la
bombe atomique
c'était réservé à quelques gouvernements
il fallait pour cela des investissements
massifs et seul pouvait servir de ça les
quelques personnes qui avaient l'accès
au bouton et tout ça l'ia c'est une arme
terrible mais ça a rien à voir ou sens
où tout le monde se notre assise se
démocratise et il faut que les uns les
autres et tous ceux qui ont des idéaux
et qui croient s'empare de l'ia prennent
à s'en servir ce muscle et comprennent
comment l'utiliser alors il ya un pays
le canada qui est en train de se
positionner par rapport à lla d'une
façon intéressante et leurs discours
très clairement c'est ici on est libre
comme les états unis d'amérique mais on
est éthique qu'on peut l'être en europe
ils ont un mot clé qui utilisent qui
énorme que d'atari non prédateurs ont
fait pas concurrence aux universités en
leur piquant la mer chercheurs ont fait
des partenariats avec eux avec des
fellows avec une communauté on veut
servir l'intérêt public il se positionne
là-dessus et il attire des capitaux en
quantité importante
il ya dans les grandes forces du monde
bien sûr des forces qui vont servir des
buts qui sont pas bons pour la planète
ou pas bon pour la société elle a
d'autres qui sont très attentifs à
servir la planète et la société
quand on voit des technologies comme à
la frontière de la corée du nord et de
la corée du sud
avec des sentinelles vous en avez
entendu parler un petit peu ces
sentinelles qui
l'autonomie dans la menace l'état lé
premier signal signal sonore deuxième
signal balles en caoutchouc troisième
signal
balle létale
qu'est ce que vous en pensez comment la
france
réagit par rapport à ça c'est politique
qui est responsable c'est l'intelligence
artificielle programme est celui qu'elle
promeut qui a programmé qui a entraîné
des robots tueurs en premier l'armée
commence qu'on peut compter a bien sûr
c'est un sujet qu'il faut aborder en
face et tout le monde a sa
responsabilité
les scientifiques pour être bien
d'informer
les ingénieurs bien sûr sur ce qu'ils
font sur ce qu'on leur demande qui est
possible et puis les politiques qui
prennent la responsabilité
vous avez peut-être vu parce que ça a
été un peu virale le clip très marquants
qui a été produit par mon collègue
stuart russell avec les essaims avec les
essaims de robot tueur
je je je chercherai pas à faire le blasé
c'est un clip qui m'a beaucoup marqué
moi et sur trop seul c'est pas un
prophète illuminé c'est un expert en
intelligence artificielle même si là il
est un peu en dehors de sa zone de
confort scientifique
il a conscience et on a conscience qu'on
peut faire des choses qui sont
effrayantes absolument effrayante et que
là dedans c'est pareil il faut que les
politiques prennent la responsabilité il
faut qu'on évite à tout prix ce qui
serait une prolifération de ce genre de
choses et il faut qu'on avance sur des
accords mondiaux par rapport à ça la
même façon qu'on a travaillé sur des
accords tels que sur les guerres
biologiques
sur le sur le nucléaire et ses
négociations compliquées qui souvent
sont pas bien en cours on a
une difficulté il faut regarder aussi
par rapport à ce domaine bien sûr en ya
c'est que c'est un sujet ce qui est
difficile à cerner
bien sûr intelligence artificielle est
déjà utilisée à des degrés divers dans
de nombreuses applications
technologiques militaires
et
donner une définition précise on peut
pas le faire définir une tête nucléaire
oui on le sait aussi un truc basé sur
sur l'armé nucléaire oui ça rentre dans
telle ou telle catégorie non pas dire
qu'un truc rentrer dans une catégorie ia
ou paillat il faut travailler sur les
usages travailler sur le droit
international le droit de la guerre mais
aussi les questions de défense or acte
de guerre et il faut arriver à
porter le débat au tous les niveaux de
responsabilité mais citoyens les experts
les politiques les conséquences on
change de sujet on va arrêter les robes
ou tueur à l'échangé la bon on va passer
à un autre sujet un peu plus anxiogène
l'emploi ouais 80% des métiers vont être
comme vous le dites impact est touché
on en fait quoi de ces gens là on les
met sous tutelle d'intelligence
artificielle avec des robots qui leur
apportent des petits cocktails
fait comme le japon avec on ne fait pas
venir de migrants parce que bon bah les
japonais vous connaissez leur perception
du mélange ethnique c'est pas un peu
leurs tripes ici on est cacherait une
version plus politiquement correct
mickael qui et c'est le fait qu'il ya un
fond
culturaliste shinto is dans lequel les
objets les robots ont une âme et tout ça
on verra l'âme des robots et le droit
des robots juste après quand on voit les
japonais développé des nurses pour
s'occuper de leurs populations et de
leur démographie vieillissante
en france comment ça va se comporter en
europe commencé à se comporter avec la
la paupérisation de tous et en premier
c'est psychologiquement très important
de se dire c'est à nous de trouver la
solution nous en tant que cité
en deuxième vous me parlez de
vieillissement mais vieillissement ou
pas vieillissement on manque cruellement
de bras dans toutes sortes de secteurs
ici qui ont trait à s'occuper de la
personne manque de monde dans les
hôpitaux on manque de médecins on manque
de personnes pour garder nos enfants il
nous manque d'emplois qualifiés nous
manque aussi des emplois peu qualifiés
dans nos hôpitaux psychiatriques c'est
incroyable le manque de gens qualifiés
et aussi de genre de gens de bonne
volonté de jean de gens non qualifiés
c'est un c'est un vrai problème et c'est
un sujet comment on va
arriver à renforcer
macroscopiquement tous les emplois qui
demandent plus d'empathie plus de
contacts humains l'inde mais un collègue
de la silicon valley dont j collègues
mais c'était un entrepreneur plus
qu'elle on est bien à bordeaux nancy
nettement honnêtement je connais tu mens
je serai plus vous dire qui sait si un
gars qui a fait fortune avec une très
grosse une très grosse entreprise ne
serait plus vous dire laquelle
entreprise et si vous donniez une
demi-heure pour fouiller dans mes
archives je le retrouvais facilement
mais là dedans en tout cas et disent et
c'est un exemple pour un temps oui à
venir conducteur de bus à se retrouver
au chômage parce que ce sera un bus
automatique
mais pourra
garder les enfants
lou s'occuper de les faire d'animation
avec eux et faire un job qui peut-être
sera plus nobles pour l'humanité
s'occuper des gens plutôt que de
conduire qui est quelque chose d'assez
mécanique vous savez pas très malin
c'est il faut quand même avoir beaucoup
de dextérité pour qu'on est dans un
camion il faut avoir beaucoup de
dextérité pour conduire un camion c'est
vrai mais bord du kachin oui c'est
quelque chose qu'un algorithme sera
faire un jour de façon meilleure qu'à
meilleurs crus main un jour papa est ce
que cet algorithme va pouvoir par
exemple une histoire personnelle un jour
je me suis endormi au volant et c'est un
camionneur qui m'a sauvé la vie parce
qu'il m'a vu m'endormir il s'est
débrouillé pour moi éveillé et ensuite
je lui ai payé un café cette
intelligence artificielle à cette
conscience que cette intelligence
artificielle va respecter
c'était trivialement les l'oise les lois
d'asimov
c'est bien que vous mentionniez les lois
d'asimov qui était un peu qu'ils sont un
peu une référence en la matière même si
en pratique elles sont impossibles à
mettre en oeuvre tel quel et c'est tout
une affaire de savoir comment on
pourrait les coder
l'intelligence artificielle qui affiche
de la compassion et qui vole à votre
secours c'est pas pour demain ni pour
après demain ça c'est sûr
en revanche pour venir l'exemple que
vous indiquez l'intelligence
artificielle qui vous réveille quand
vous endormez volant c'est beaucoup plus
facile à faire 1 il ya
une difficulté majeure quand même dans
ce que je disais en société enfin il
faut un sujet qui fait au courant qu'on
aborde sait comment organiser le
transfert transfert de valeur il
transfert d'emplois la répartition des
richesses répartition des richesses mais
aussi comment les emplois peu vont se
créer comment les filières avancent eux
vont s'adapter
évidemment qu'il va y avoir des
questions de redistribution taxation et
ainsi de suite et que faudra trouver le
bon équilibre
quand on taxe trop fort un domaine
l'empêchent de développer ça peut être
embêtant dans un contexte de compétition
mondiale en particulier si on ne taxe
pas on laisse la richesse accumulée dans
ce
dans ce domaine et le transfert va pas
se faire
ça va pas être simple mais un problème
posé déjà en partie résolu et
on est tous convaincus les uns les
autres que
les solutions passeront aussi par des
formations adaptées
des
accroissements compétences de nos
organismes de type pôle emploi de type
réflexion et tout ça
salaire universel parce que vous êtes
comme laurent alexandre à dire que le
salaire ni vient cette favoriser l
intelligence artificielle forte
moi je
n'ai pas de
conviction forte sur le salaire
universel je serais pas surpris d'être à
titre personnel ici je n'expose pas eu
tous une position officielle de
mouvement ou ce que vous voulez mais à
titre personnel je serais pas surpris
que ça se généralise peu à peu que
d'abord on n'appellera pas salaires
universel on appellera ça l'impôt
négatif sur les bas revenus
et que
ça soit ça vienne dans le cadre d'un
mouvement plus général qui sera le fait
de protéger les individus plus que les
emplois de donner aux individus la
possibilité de choisir entre différentes
possibilités un monde beaucoup plus
flexible certainement qui viendra
ce monde flexible dans un contexte
géopolitique tendu avec des flux
migratoires
exacerbés par rapport à des erreurs
passées
comme en intelligence artificielle
pourra nous aider j'avais tout ça
d'abord après de façon générale
appréhender la complexité
quand les modèles sont inexistants ou
impossible à mettre en oeuvre
regardez un monde
très différent qui celui de la finance
internationale
pensez à la finance internationale
comment un monde très dur parce que
un monde qui pense d'abord à son
enrichissement un monde dans lequel la
compétition internationale est
extrêmement forte c'est un monde qui est
aussi impacté de façon violente par les
changements technologiques quand le
numérique est arrivé les traders humains
se sont vite fait remplacer enfin
l'ancien sont vite fait remplacer par
des algorithmes et par des des courante
des experts en algorithmes des gens qui
avaient un profil différent on pense
souvent à ce monde comme le monde qui
violent par rapport au reste mais c'est
un monde qui est aussi touchée de façon
violente par les vagues technologiques
actuellement il est aussi touchée de
façon très forte par la montée
d'intelligence artificielle c'est
simplement les pouces boutons qui sont
touchés sur le contexte de la finance
internationale quand je dis pouces
bouton c des traders
je continue jument bon mon exemple pour
dire que dans ce monde qui aussi en
interne est en proie de plus en plus
d'instabilité des algorithmes de plus en
plus mystérieux des mouvements de plus
en plus rapide une pression de plus en
plus forte là dedans c'est un monde où
les outils d'intelligence artificielle
plus pragmatique avec -10 des a priori
rendez rendre des services
importants et là où le trader à
l'ancienne le compte à l'ancienne disait
je vais modéliser ça avec des hypothèses
allaient modèle de black choses allaient
les acteurs indépendants ceci cela et
puis ça me donnait telle ou telle chose
il était très contrainte par des modèles
le nouveau et beaucoup moins contraints
et le nouveau
ce
utilisa pas tellement d'à priori mais ça
dans des grandes moulinette de modèles
big data il peut comme ça mieux
appréhender la complexité les multiples
paramètres et bien à l'échelle de la
planète géante est que c'est ça aussi
qu'on a besoin est que dans nos modèles
d'appréhension de l'environnement aussi
de la biodiversité au site qui sait quoi
on va de dans notre approche on va de
plus en plus faire confiance à l
approche pragmatique prenant en compte
plein de donner plein de paramètres et
moins recherchés la modélisation le
piège ça serait d'oublier complètement
la modélisation bien sûr il ya un enjeu
dans un peu tous les secteurs d'arriver
à marier les approches et à et les
modèles pour l'instant les ia utilise
plus de modèles
mais globalement en termes d'outils
de surveillance
d'outils de pilotage petit diagnostic on
va monter en compétences alors deux
choses premièrement le black swan ce
qu'on a à modéliser le black swan avec
le cygne noir avec les noirs géants de
l'intelligence artificielle et vous
parlez de surveillance
on va vous laisser parler du black swan
qui on reviendra sur la surveillance
globalement on a été assez mauvais en
tant qu' en tant qu'espèce à prédire les
événements catastrophiques les grands
effets d'entraînement on l'a vu dans
certains craquent et
il y a
un secteur qui s'est développée de
l'analyse des risques systémiques
quelles sont les situations dans
lesquelles c'est pas un acteur qui a une
défaillance mais à laquelle tout un
système est entraînée dans une spirale
terrible
et on a vu que nos modèles étaient pas
adapté on a vu que nos modèles qui
préside prédisait gentiment dès que
certes que les événements rares seraient
rarissime nous des leçons me se sont
fait mettre en défaut parce qu'on avait
des situations la psychologie joue un
rôle important et que c'était pas prévu
ou parce qu'on avait un domaine où les
corrélations entre acteurs jouent un
rôle important et qu'on n'avait pas
anticipé ou parce qu'on était
complètement en dehors de notre zone de
confort mais cost est habitué en plus
les modèles hors zone
avec des outils plus pragmatique tel
qu'il ya on va être mieux armé pour les
appréhender
c'est black swans on va aussi pouvoir
être bien meilleur sur l'exploration
commencé et pour caricaturer ya trois
grandes familles dia une famille où on
s'occupe de modéliser les causes et les
conséquences une famille où on s'occupe
de faire l'apprentissage par la donner
par exemple et une troisième stratégie
consiste à l'exploration comme on l'a
fait avec alpha go à explorer des
stratégies compris santé gic que les
humains n'avaient jamais rencontré
stratégie par renforcement cette
stratégie parents forcément on peut
imaginer que sur bien des sujets on va
pouvoir la mettre en oeuvre pour
détecter l avance des scénarios
catastrophes se demandait à lait qu'est
ce qui peut se passer de pires qu'il ya
un vrai risque systémique là et ça ça va
être un gros progrès par rapport à ce
que nos modèles pouvaient faire
surveillance quand on voit vous avez vu
le vidéo chinoise de la reconnaissance
de plaques instantanée avec une multi
perception des plaques des visages des
attitudes des démarches
tél des attroupements des voix quand on
est une société qui est entier dans
entièrement monitorer grâce à nos
téléphones portables les applications
qui traînent dedans là c'était les
caméras de vidéo surveillance vidéo
protection excusez moi ça nous emmène ou
dans une société où le capitalisme
s'essouffle les tensions s'exacerbent
on n'est pas en train de se mettre une
épée de damoclès au-dessus de la tête
d'un pouvoir qui pourrait prendre le
contrôle de ces est-ce que c'est pas des
lames de rasoir donner un singe
et on disait exactement la même chose de
l'arme atomique il ya quelques décennies
c'est le parallèle que je voulais en
faire et on a dit la même chose aussi de
la biologie synthétique l'a vu on a vu
le programme nucléaire se faire je vais
résumer ça trivialement mais signé
anticipé modéliser ou sur le coin d'une
table nous engageant sur 100 ans avec
des déchets extraordinaire
l'incapacité de recycler l'incapacité de
déconstruire est ce que l'intelligence
artificielle
c'est pas notre lame de rasoir ou notre
projet nucléaire qu'on va laisser à nos
des générations futures est-ce que c'est
pas les rendre alors
d'abord lie à
la génération d'après dit stop utilisant
jamais on peut le faire le déchet
nucléaire c'est autrement plus engageant
un c ils sont là pour cent mille ans et
davantage sans ans et la durée prévue du
chantier 6 géo qui permettra de les
enterrer très profond et ja poussière
sous le tapis oui mais sous un tapis
profond et il vaut mieux le mettre dans
un tapis profond que dans un tapis
à faible profondeur là parce que pour le
coup le tapis à faible profondeur si
d'ici milan ou même 100 ans on retrouve
dessus on retombe dessus où on a un qui
sait quel est l'avenir géopolitique du
monde dans un siècle pas moi et
le ne pas enfouir ne rien faire ça peut
être un vrai vrai vrai danger
maintenant sûr il ya ici par l'humanité
c'est son destin on va dire pour faire
la philosophie à dessous que de se doter
d'outils de plus en plus puissants et de
plus en plus perfectionné avec lesquels
on peut faire le bien ou le mal
quand la bombe atomique a explosé
certains commentateurs ont dit einstein
dit l'humanité n'est pas prête pour cela
et puis d'autres ont commenté en disant
ça peut penser jeudi wells qui avaient
anticipé un peu ce genre de choses qui
avait dans un de ses romans à 10,7 à
limiter de se prendre en main ça peut
être sa destruction ou salves à sion
selon la façon dont on le monte on le
prend et intelligence artificielle c'est
rien d'autre que pousser à la grande
très grande efficacité
nos techniques algorithmique sur
l'utilisent pour lui bien ça pourrait
être très très bien ça pourrait être la
médecine personnalisée ça pourra être
rendre plus sûr en eau vie plus longue
plus sur une meilleure communication et
si on utilise mal ça peut être très très
mal alors l'important est de
sensibiliser tout le monde à ça
l'important est d'en discuter des ducs
et très tôt à ça et de savoir que
à la fin des fins la responsabilité est
à la société elle est politique il faut
qu'ils soient bien informés et qui se
défausse pas sur la technologie on n'a
pas le droit de dire c'est comme ça
c'est inévitable avec telle technologie
qui c'est qui va décider que ça va vers
le bien enfin le bisou bien c'est ce que
c'est nous c'est ce que nous on fait
d'abord
bien mal tout ça c'est relatif bien sûr
on a des on a une notion
d'intérêt public sur soi des cours de
citoyenneté des cours de morale on a les
valeurs qu'on partage et puis on en
parle en tête que ce aider les uns les
autres c'est bien que se soigner c'est
bien que partage et c'est assez bien et
ainsi de suite et la croissance c'est
bien alors ça on peut en discuter une
croissance pour la croissance a pas de
sens bon et quand vous en ciel c'est
compliqué nos et démographique
exponentielle c'est compliqué comme on
sait bien aussi sur ces questions là
c'est tout dans le différentiel aussi si
vous avez le continent asiatique est en
forte croissance et l'europe n'y crois
pas ça veut dire que les investisseurs
vont aller investir en asie et en europe
ça veut dire que l'intérêt de l'europe
seront moins bien défendus ça veut dire
que les valeurs européennes auront moins
les moyens de s'imposer et ainsi de
suite alors on sait bien par ailleurs
que la croissance ça regroupe tout un
tas d'indicateurs qui sont pas forcément
bien que les guerres sont des vecteurs
de croissance fenomeno est donc on veut
pas plonger dans la politique les
guerres sont toujours le prolongement de
la politique non vous y allez fort là
non c'est l'été mais alors
les guerres sont
aussi est
très souvent des prolongements de deux
d'incompréhension de
les résultantes de forts déséquilibres
le fait que les web
mais bon allez
on arrive bientôt à la fin allez j'ai
des questions que je vais vous lire à la
volée vous agissez ce qu'il y avait à
choisir et ensuite j'en aurai 2 à la fin
donc je vis ce qui nous reste à passer
comme question ça ce sera peut-être dont
dans ces qui nous point d'interrogation
politique plein d'interrogations peuple
point d'interrogation
donc quoi est-ce qu'ils investissent ah
ouais vous allez toucher un petit peu de
sous avec la médaille fields vous avez
investi dans quoi vous avez pris du bide
cogne vous avez investi dans la
recherche dans la charité vous avez fait
une fondation
ensuite un monde flexible pour
interrogation est-ce à l'humain d'être
adapté à l'infini point d'interrogation
et la dernière c'est qu'elle ait le
pouvoir de la population sur l'avenir de
l'intelligence artificielle peut-on
d'influencé des députés ayant une
connaissance très limitée de
l'intelligence artificielle auront-ils
la légitimité de légiférer sur son
avenir pour l'interrogation donc je vous
donne ça à la volée ouais allez je
prends la question rigolotes sur la
médaille fields médaille fillon gagnent
peu d'argent venir c'est le genre de
10000 ou quelque chose comme ça
deux mille dix mille euros j'ai gagné
beaucoup plus en faisant des conférences
ici et là ou en vendant des ou en
vendant des livres que qu'avec la mise à
l'heure à peu près la moitié de l'argent
que j'ai touché pour la médaille fils je
vais dépenser pour offrir un super repas
dans un
restaurant 3 étoiles à mes collègues à
l'occasion d'un à l'occasion d'une
conférence ben
j'ai pas de fondations en revanche j'ai
fondé un fonds de dotation pour
l'institut henri poincaré qui vise à
rapprocher le monde de la recherche et
le monde de l'entreprise avec surtout
des actions de culture scientifique en
vue sera l'un des acteurs majeurs dans
le financement de la maison des
mathématiques qui devrait qui vous ira
en 2020 à l'institut pour permettre à
tout le monde de mieux comprendre ce que
c'est que la mathématique son histoire
son développement son avenir on a
d'ailleurs un projet assez innovante de
médiation mathématiques par réalité
augmentée sur lequel on est en train de
travailler dans ce cadre là ça mène à la
question suivante qui est
l'acculturation de tous les acteurs et
en particulier du politique et oui c'est
un problème si les politiques ont pas
une assez bonne compréhension des dans
le jeu technologique sur lesquels ils
vont légiférer c'est un problème et
c'est l'un de mes chevaux de bataille à
l'assemblée nationale on est plutôt
musard mais qu'est ce que c'était le cas
avant parce qu'il ya pas mal avec
dernières élections il ya pas mal de
profils scientifiques qui se sont
retrouvés député et on travaille aussi
je travaille aussi à faire vivre ce
dialogue j'ai pris la présidence
maintenant vice présidence de l'office
parlementaire scientifique qui vise à
instruire les débats à l'interface entre
politique et citoyen je travaille par
exemple sur l'ia on a fait il n'ya pas
longtemps une séance d'atelier avec mes
collègues députés et sénateurs pour
débattre entre nous hors des caméras et
en dehors du gouvernement deux sujets
liés à l'ia et on se posait des
questions un peu dans le style de celle
que vous ne posiez les emplois
l'avenir de ducation de la formation
tout ça la force des lobbys dans tout ça
à ce qu'il y ait des lobbys qui poussent
pour aller à gauche et à droite il ya
des lobbys sur tous les sujets bien sûr
et ma position c'est que il faut pas
avoir peur d'écouter un lobby à
l'occasion pourvu qu'on se demande
toujours quel est le contre acteurs qui
pourraient me donner un son de cloche
opposé différents et que j'écoute l'un
et l'autre ou qui le paye
alors non ce que jamais payé à 8,66 paye
le lobbyiste qui y voit là évidemment
absolument savoir remonter le flux
savoir qui qui est à l'origine
absolument où il atterré on a une sur
ces sujets là on est on est certainement
moins naïfs que ce que ça a pu être
certaine époque je suis frappé aussi de
voir comment mon administration je veux
dire les administrateurs à l'assemblée
nationale sont assez bons pour instruire
ça quand par exemple reçoit une demande
dès que je dis là il ya une demande de
quelqu'un qu'elle est intéressante
caisses toujours pensé ils me répondent
souvent ah oui mais attention ils ont
partie liée avec tel est l intérêt c'est
une démarche de lobbying et ce qu'ils
nous disent est ce que vous vouliez ou
pas les recevoir et on répond en
connaissance de cause bon
il ya une sous hédé des politiques de
certains politiques en tout cas de
saisir davantage du sujet et ça rejoint
aussi très clair revendications delà des
citoyens
si
je pense si j'ai obtenu le score que
j'ai obtenus aux élections législatives
combien
j'ai eu quelque chose c'est plus je
crois que j'ai eu 47 % au premier tour
et je sais plus au deuxième tour
peut-être beaucoup peut-être 70% en tout
cas un vrai un vrai vrai score élevé qui
était la marque de le
ce que les fans clairement les citoyens
disent et c'est bien d'avoir
des scientifiques qui ont vont en
politique et qui vont apporter leur
expertise là bas et qui permettront aux
politiques de juger et délibérée en
connaissance de cause et ça c'est
quelque chose qui est important je crois
on veut que les sculpteurs d'un show les
brasseurs de fumée sont remplacés par
des dons qu'ils maîtrisent correctement
leur sujet et on veut aussi assemblée
qui est des gens qui délibère sur
l'entreprise en ayant été entrepreneur
pas que bien sûr mais qui en est qu'ils
fassent qui apportent leur voix des gens
qui travaillent sur
l'environnement légifère son
environnement après avoir été dans des
ong sur l'environnement et ainsi de
suite
une petite question qui vient de se
greffer en plus vous êtes indépendant
face la république en marche
indépendance d'esprit on est toujours à
la fois solidaire j'ai utilisé le mot
solidaire plutôt que dépendant et on
garde son garde son indépendance mais
nous étions évidence aussi non alors moi
j'ai été il y en leader de la
french-american foundation
mais aussi ou en tout cas très proche de
la fondation france chine et aussi en
leader delà
de 2011 leaders européens qui était un
projet porté par europanova dans lequel
j'ai milité pendant des années et fredo
viola et
ça me pose enfin tout cas j'assume
pleinement le fait d'être leader il se
dit book qui a beaucoup de fantasmes sur
les sur layon leader
c'est surtout un espace de discussions
et de et d'ouverture et de contacts fait
un soft power américain c'est un sauf
pas voir ça fait partie de la diplomate
de la sof pas voir aussi bien
américaines que françaises puisque ça
permet aussi des acteurs français de
de rencontrer des homologues américains
et de comprendre et ça permet aussi à
des acteurs français avec d'intérêt
international de ceux de se rencontrer
mais on peut pas à la fois
reproché légitimement à nos politiques
d'être un peu trop repliés sur la france
et leur reprocher de participer à des
institutions dans lesquelles ils sont au
contact des uns et des autres vous iriez
au contact des russes j'irai aussi au
contact des russes absolument et on a eu
pas longtemps d'ailleurs une rencontre
entre députés de l'office parlementaire
scientifiques français et leurs
homologues russes science a toujours la
science a toujours parlé des
scientifiques russes j'en ai connu
quantité ils ont bouleversé tout en
séance surtout mathématiques physique
théorique en tout cas la science serait
pas la même sans enjeu serait pas ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui dans certains
domaines sans la peau russe et puis on a
la une
une allée dire civilisation en tout cas
une nation avec une histoire
extraordinaire je fais partie de ceux
qui sont être extrêmement idéaliste qui
pensent que la construction européenne
ne sera achevé que quand l'europe
comprendra le royaume uni et la russie
en tout cas l'angleterre parce que
peut-être le royaume uni seront exposés
qui c'est l'angleterre et la russie ça
prendra du temps mais il mais c'est un
mode dreamers taino dernier one comme on
disait
dernière question qu'on pose à tous nos
invités ouais c'est même pas une
question s'est laissé un conseil pour
les jeunes générations une bouteille à
la mer sur internet quelque chose
d'impérissables protégé par
le net mais si vous aviez un tracé pour
eux d ici là en face en
fait on me pose souvent la question
conseil pour les jeunes et j'y réfléchis
et par rapport à propre expérience et
j'ai trois conseils
premier conseil ou pas se laisser
enfermer dans les cases dans le temps et
l'occasion de sortir de sa case il faut
les saisir en tant que mathématicien
j'ai été analyste et probabiliste et
géomètres c'était important tant que
chercheur j'ai été parisien j'ai été
lyonnais c'était super important en tant
que
professionnellement parlant j'étais
chercheur plis j'ai été directeur
d'institut maintenant politique super
important demandant dans mon
développement est très souvent on arrive
à faire jouer l'expérience qu'on a
acquis dans sa vie précédente d'un oubli
donc un pas de
4,2 mouvement
quand dès qu'on commence à maîtriser un
sujet c'est qu'il est temps passer au
suivant ou de réfléchir au suivant et
bout gérer pour le principe de bouger
c'est pas mal
troisièmement très important laisser de
la place au hasard
le hasard c'est extraordinaire dans la
société actuelle où il ya plein de
paramètres plein de choses il ya plein
d'occasions de coups de chance qui se
présente
il faut savoir repérer quand un coup de
chance est là et le saisir
et le hasard se débrouille pour vous
faire aller c'est un peu comme
l'intelligence artificielle d'ailleurs
dans des configurations une situation
que vous auriez jamais imaginé alors
c'est pas pour autant qu'il faut perdre
vos valeurs vos amours sans quoi vous
croyez mais laisser le hasard vous
guider au moins un peu et même un peu
plus voilà
on a le temps d'une dernière juste aller
oui c'est à la communauté pourquoi
population s'avancer pourquoi c'est pas
le paradis dans ce monde et à quoi sert
la science et il avait déjà cédé bonnes
questions
en premier
plus les situations
sont compliquées
plus on fait appel à la science
la science résout pas tout d'un coup
quand on résout un problème en science
in à nouveau qui se présente quand
l'humanité raison d'un problème aussi
nouveau se présente on a plus ou moins
résolu à l'échelle de l'humanité le
problème de la santé quand je dis ça
c'est une très grosse caricature bien
sûr parce qu'il ya encore plein de
problèmes d'accès à l'eau saine des
problèmes d'épidémie les choses comme ça
mais
globalement avec les
avec la médication moderne avec des
campagnes de vaccination avec d'autres
choses on a résolu le problème de la
santé il s'est ensuivi le problème de la
surpopulation
bien sûr qu'on est en train de gérer
d'apprendre à
d'apprendre à contenir petit à petit qui
est pas facile bon chaque fois qu'on
progresse et qu'on résout un problème
une à nouveau qui se présente et c'est
un peu notre destin
et ça va continuer sans doute assez
longuement mais on peut pas s'empêcher
et c'est normal de vouloir résoudre les
problèmes aujourd'hui on vit plus
longtemps qu'avant on a accès à beaucoup
plus d'enrichissement culturel beaucoup
plus d'occasions de
on peut avoir accès au moins dans
certains pays à une nourriture saine a
une grande qualité de l'éducation est ce
que vous voulez
et on est content
c'est venu avec aussi globalement c'est
venu avec la croissance qui a n'a pas
que des côtés positifs
l'industrialisation est venu avec la
pollution massive le plastique qui était
un progrès chimiques considérable mène à
la pollution des océans qu'on connaît
maintenant aussi on apprend comme ça au
fur et à mesure les revers des médailles
il ya un truc dans lequel on a été très
mauvais globalement
c'est apprendre à être heureux à
l'échelle de l'humanité est mauvais et
on voit on le voit bien quand on voyage
que c'est assez peu corrélés le fait
d'être heureux avec le développement de
la société les indices de richesse indue
technologies
vous voyagez en afrique et
je découvert l'afrique en tant que
scientifique sept ans depuis j'y vais
tous les ans je fais des cours je
participe à des actions là bas j'y vais
pas seulement pour aider j'ai vu aussi
parce que ça me rend heureux et parce
que là bas on découvre que même dans des
villes où lundi ce développement est
très en dessous de ce qu'on a ici les
gens sont heureux
c'est caricatural ce que je dis mais
globalement les gens sont pas plus
malheureux qu ici même je dirais ils
sont plus tendus ici qu'ils ne sont là
bas donc on a été très mauvais pour
apprendre à être heureux et on voit
qu'il ya une réaction qui est en train
de se faire petit à petit je vais je
suis allé ça m'est arrivé d'aller à la
conférence ted bien sûr à vancouver ça
m'a frappé l'an dernier de voir comment
il y avait une tendance de fond qui
revenait dans pleins intervention sur le
fait que c'est pas la technologie qui va
résoudre nos problèmes mais qu'il
fallait apprendre à être autonomes avoir
notre indépendance de la nouvelle
question sur les monts ma position par
rapport au mouvement mais c'est un peu
pareil
et solidaire on utilise la technologie
on est avec mais il faut apprendre aussi
à pas lui faire confiance aveuglément et
il le disait de façon forte les gens ne
vous laissez pas mangé par la
technologie
apprenez à vous réserver du temps à
réfléchir à vous à ce que vous voulez a
pas vous laisser tout dicté la solution
n'est pas seulement dans l'aide de la
technologie elle aussi en vous et je
pense est très important en tant que ce
site et on a été très mauvais on est
tout le temps frustré on se rend pas
compte de notre chance et bon mais on
doit en avoir conscience et
collectivement évoluer vers sa plus
d'humains plus de
apprendre à s'écouter ce même
cédric villani mercy a pu continuer ses
discussions pendant des heures
delhaize était bien vous êtes banshee
c'est bien ça suscite le débat et on
aime bien toujours en science cette idée
que la confrontation
n'est la bonne discussion et le contact
amical et j'ai été
c'est une des grandes choses que nous on
a pris deux collègues scientifiques
russes d'ailleurs qui n'ayant pas
l'appareil pour ce dégommer les uns les
autres dans les séminaires scientifiques
mais c'est aussi de là que sont nées les
grandes théories cédric villani merci
merci coupé
[Musique]
e